[Music]
tonight on global national
through mountains of rubble they keep
searching for signs of life
devastating earthquakes in southern
turkey have flattened thousands of
buildings including huge apartment
blocks in dozens of cities in southern
turkey and Northern Syria the first hit
just after 4 a.m while people were still
asleep the lucky managed to escape and
then nine hours later
another one
this journalist was reporting live when
Panic struck again
foreign
s collapsed
and through the dust the camera keeps
rolling
the crew helps a mother get her children
out
more than 3 700 people are known to have
died in turkey and in Syria the World
Health Organization fears those numbers
could Rise eight-fold And Then There are
the injured that number has already
surpassed thirteen thousand here's where
it happened the epicenter of the initial
quake 7.8 in magnitude was near gazian
tap in Southeastern turkey and was felt
as far away as Lebanon and Israel the
second the magnitude 7.5 hit along the
same fault line just 100 kilometers
North plus there have been multiple
powerful aftershocks right across the
region good evening and thanks for
joining us search teams that managed to
make it to the earthquake zone are
working through the night tonight turkey
is appealing to the world for help but
local airports are damaged as are roads
and freezing winter weather is adding to
what is already a nightmare scenario on
the ground our coverage tonight begins
with Mike droulet
the sun had yet to rise on southeastern
turkey the full scope of the damage
unknown as rescue workers began combing
through collapsed buildings
a young girl saved
her brother a few minutes later the fate
of their parents unknown Witnesses say
the 7.8 magnitude Quake one of the
largest ever recorded in Turkey in
Northern Syria shook the ground for two
solid minutes the shaking continued
through the morning and then roughly
nine hours after the earthquake
a second one measuring 7.5 struck to the
north weakened buildings collapsed
sending Rescuers scrambling for safety
in Northern Syria buildings already
damaged from 11 years of Civil War
crumbled this family like so many others
has no idea where to go
we're scared for the children she says
we went back home but a new earthquake
took place so we went back to the street
help is on the way turkey says it had
offers of assistance from 45 countries
but the window to pull survivors from
the rubble is quickly closing and the
situation is even more dire in Syria
Toronto's Global medic pulled its
operations from the war-torn area
several years ago they are so
overmatched right now with what they're
facing and there's nobody coming in to
help them there's no International Teams
there's no access in they can't come in
from the Syrian side there's only one
route in from the Turkish side
complicating matters it will take months
to assess the building Still Standing
throughout the massive area impacted by
the earthquakes already thousands are
dead and long-term
that could climb higher if enough
shelters aren't provided to fend off the
cold
we'll be cold here until morning
freezing getting wet says the Survivor
we have no place to go no place to stay
my God we don't even have a bed
Global News
time really is of the essence shelter
heat food and water are needed urgently
for those who have lost their homes and
rescue teams with sniffer dogs and heavy
equipment are essential too as Redmond
Shannon reports many of those caught in
the devastation had already lost
everything during the war in Syria
a father inconsolable
his newborn baby did not survive
[Applause]
I'm waiting to pull out my brother and
his seven children says this man in
Northern Syria expecting that none of
them have survived
many of those affected across the border
in Turkey are also syrians who fled the
Civil War like had team El Abdullah we
had this situation before when a
military airplane they opened the houses
and they fallen down so it's almost same
feeling her team and his family spent
much of the night and day out in the
winter cold too scared to go back inside
we were things like that okay should we
go back our home but it's still
dangerous but also here is so cold
the day's second large earthquake only
adding to the sense of dread for her
team's family including his grandmother
who couldn't return to her badly damaged
home my family and my grandmother my
father family because they are stay with
us like we're still wearing our clothes
because we're still ready to go out a
team says his family doctor is dead and
a close friend living in hatai province
is missing you can easily see the line
of the earthquake
ruining exactly a series of Apartments
more at Aslan lives in gaziantep he says
the immediate need is to establish
proper shelter for those who are
homeless his fear is that the true
extent of the disaster has yet to become
clear there's a great number of people
right now and exactly we don't know it I
mean how many people are under the
buildings we don't know that
even the small stories of Hope are
encased in sadness
toddler Reich had survived but most of
her family including her mother did not
Redmond Shannon Global News
turkey has taken in more Syrian refugees
than any other country more than 3.6
million people many of them are in
gazian tap right in the earthquake zone
inside Syria members of the Civil
Defense Forces are working on rescues
earlier today we heard from Noor kormosh
a trt reporter about the situation in
idlib Syria
the catastrophic disaster that hit the
areas in Northwestern Syria is still
ongoing as the as the severe earthquake
has started from a third
project to the areas in Northwestern
Syria as you see behind me the civil
defense teams have been working
relentlessly since the beginning of this
disaster where these research ads rescue
teams in the civil defense have been
working on evacuating the civilians that
are still currently stuck under these
Rebels and of course also evacuating the
civilians from a dangerous areas
officials stated that no official and
defined
statistics have been published due to
the continuation of the death toll is
still on known the widespread damages
across the areas of Northwestern Syria
made the response even more complicated
for the civil defense and other ngos
we're currently moving from one area
into another to cover the latest updates
on the advantages that hit these areas
that is newer Commerce a journalist in
idlib Syria well the first 24 to 48
hours are critical to saving the lives
of those trapped a number of countries
have mobilized search teams or have
promised to send Aid here's what
Canada's prime minister said today
our hearts go out to the families the
communities deeply affected by this
terrible terrible event Canada is
looking at how we can help directly and
immediately but also how we can work
with the International Community to be
there for people who are suffering right
now in the immediate and for the long
term with me from Ottawa is our bureau
chief Mercedes Stevenson Mercedes what
is turkey asking for what is Canada
capable of providing Donna turkey is
asking for help urgently there are of
course believed to be thousands of
people trapped underneath buildings and
it's very cold right now in turkey that
means their time is running out I spoke
with a senior Turkish Source today who
told me that one of the primary things
they are hoping the Canadian government
could send are medium search and rescue
teams these teams can go for about 24 to
72 hours without needing sustainment and
they're experts at Urban search and
rescue being able to dig through the
buildings that have collapsed to pull
people out and to use heavy equipment
but the sources I'm hearing from in
Canada are saying that Canadian teams
generally don't deploy outside Canada or
outside of North America so that may not
be something that's likely to happen
despite the Turkish Ambassador actually
asking for one of the teams by name and
that is Canada task force 2. they are a
national Disaster Response Team based
out of Calgary they've told Global News
at this time that their primary area of
responsibility of course is Canada but
of gak that's the global Affairs Canada
our International Affairs Department
were to ask them to go of course in that
case they potentially could deploy but
that's not a standard activity it's
something that could be looked at by the
federal government but my sources are
telling me if a disaster response team
has not been stood up at this time this
evening it's unlikely they would make it
in time to really help the people who
might have a chance to survive other
requests that have come in from the
Turkish government include cold weather
equipment because people are freezing
they've been displaced they're looking
for expertise from the Canadian
government in surviving being very cold
conditions they're looking for monetary
donations that could help them buy
things that could help and then of
course they're also looking for Medical
Teams now in terms of what else the
Canadian government actually could
Supply most of it is the military
because they're capable of moving the
fastest Dart The Disaster Assistance
response team is probably the one most
Canadians are familiar with they don't
deploy that often but they could be sent
in this case they can do things like
water purification and they can also
help on the medical Side Medical Teams
of course another clear one the military
has doctors and nurses they were
deployed in Canada in the pandemic and
they can go overseas there's the
possibility of using Canadian c-17s or
Hercules planes to help move equipment
and people in or even ships as a
hospital ship but at this point I'm
being told that all that's been done is
Staff checks that's where they ask the
military what's available and still no
formal government decisions have been
made about what they actually want to
put on the table politically Donna of
course the fastest things they could do
or potentially send the military but it
may be more likely at this point that
they are looking at helping with the
recovery and rebuilding than the rescue
okay we'll keep watching Mercedes
Stevenson in Ottawa thanks well it was
not even close to the scale of what's
happened in Turkey but people in parts
of Ontario felt some shaking about 8 A.M
Eastern a small earthquake hit near the
Canada U.S border
[Music]
it was a 3.8 magnitude the epicenter was
near Buffalo New York it was felt on
both sides of the border and there are
no reports of any damage
on the eve of the premier's talking
Health Care with the Prime Minister we
have new polling about how Canadians
feel about turning to the private sector
that's coming up
the highly anticipated meeting between
the Prime Minister and the premiers
about health care happens tomorrow in
Ottawa the point of these meetings is to
reach some sort of consensus but with
the premiers that is never a given in
this case there are hints a deal could
involve billions of dollars in federal
funding to the provinces Mackenzie gray
has some details on how the talks might
unfold Mackenzie well Donna we're
expecting the federal government to make
a substantial offers to the premiers
tomorrow here in Ottawa and this is what
we know about the deal so far a senior
government Source tells Global News the
feds will offer the provinces a 10-year
agreement and that money is going to be
split into two separate pots the first
one will be to increase the Canada
Health transfer the other one will be to
cut individual deals with each province
now there's no word on the exact figure
Justin Trudeau is willing to offer but
it's likely short of what the province
has been asking for which is the federal
government paying for 35 percent of
Health Care respect a deal despite that
even some of the prime minister's
biggest provincial critics are
optimistic a compromise can be found
we're sitting down tomorrow to see what
is before us
um I think everyone is going in with an
open mind the Prime Minister echoing
that positive sentiment if this is going
to be a work that we're going to
continue doing uh over the coming coming
weeks as we recognize that different
provinces have different needs and
different priorities and that
flexibility is an important part of
ourselves despite talking about
flexibility Trudeau is set to put a
minimum of two conditions on the money
tomorrow the first one will be the
provinces need to share data amongst
themselves and with the feds to try and
improve outcomes and the second one is
the cash needs to be spent in the public
system so using federal dollars to
expand deals with for-profit clinics
like we recently saw Ontario Premier
Doug Ford do is off the table but
despite the positivity around all the
talks tomorrow it's unlikely a final
deal will come out of the two-hour
meeting with sources telling me Donna
the best case scenario would be an
agreement between all sides on a funding
framework going forward okay Mackenzie
gray and Ottawa thanks well health care
and lack of Access to Health Care is top
of mind for Canadians new polling done
exclusively for Global News suggests
more Canadians are willing to consider
what turning to the private for-profit
system might look like Catherine Ward
reports
we've come out at the other end with
people feeling much less confident in
the ability of the Health Care system to
deliver the services they may need when
they need them long hailed as a key part
of the Canadian identity for the most
part it's uh it's pretty much free here
in Canada new data indicates the system
has become a source of frustration I
don't like having to wait so long to get
services and Desperation I think the
Health Care system is very broken
polling done exclusively for global news
shows 85 percent of Canadians believe
drastic changes are needed roughly 6 in
10 would support the private delivery of
publicly funded health services and that
they are in favor of Private health care
for those who are able to afford it a
shift in opinions ipsos CEO Daryl
Bricker says he hasn't seen in decades
of polling what's happened to Health
Care is it's moved from being a
long-term issue to being something
that's much more immediate and people
are actually looking for Solutions and
improvements today and that they're
willing to consider things like maybe we
should have alternate methods of funding
certain types of Health Care Services
the growing favor toward private care
comes despite an increase in the cost of
living and Rising interest rates when
asked what's wrong with the health care
System 72 percent agreed that there are
not enough nurses and doctors and some
doctors caution a private model could
only make things worse we are not going
to be able to manufacture more doctors
more Hospital titles more health
services and so the people who have
trouble right now getting access to
service are going to have an even bigger
problem getting access to those Services
a move towards more privatized services
will increase the disparity of Health
outcomes for the rich and the poor Dr
Danielle Raza says investments in
not-for-profit care outside the hospital
in team-based primary care and in
community services like Physio and
long-term care would go a long way I'm
mid-career I'm just you know in the
middle of this people who have been in
this system longer than I have have said
they've never seen it as bad as they've
seen it Healthcare is a political
football and I think most of us are
tired of people handing it off Catherine
Ward Global News Toronto
democracy activists on trial ahead the
largest national security case begins in
Hong Kong
Hong Kong's largest national security
trial has begun a hearing that has been
labeled a trial of the territory's
pro-democracy movement itself
the hearings involved 47 of Hong Kong's
most prominent pro-democracy activists
most have been detained for the past two
years on security grounds and face
charges of conspiracy to commit
subversion the charges stem from an
unofficial primary election organized by
democracy supporters in July 2020. the
case is at the center of a Crackdown on
opposition and descent in Hong Kong
after the mass pro-democracy protests in
2019.
Canada is extending and expanding the
work permit program for Hong Kong
residents looking to work here the
deadline to apply for the temporary
three-year open work permit has been
extended to February 7th of 2025. it was
set to expire tomorrow eligibility has
expanded to Hong Kong residents who've
graduated from a post-secondary school
in Canada or abroad within the past 10
years before this applicants had to have
graduated within the past five years
besides mixed severity next we look at
the science behind those devastating
earthquakes in Turkey
it is hard to comprehend just how
devastating the earthquakes in Turkey
have been to people in that country and
in Syria there have been earthquakes in
Turkey before seismic activity is
nothing new for that country it is the
scale of the damage this time that's so
overwhelming Eric Sorensen takes a
closer look at the science behind the
severity
mountainous turkey is one of the world's
most active earthquake regions Turks
know what that means and what to do if
there's time to react office
as soon as the shaking slowed down we
threw ourselves outside he says turkey
experiences major seismic activity every
two years or so this Village in 1957
became a ghost town after an earthquake
in 1970 thousands of homes and public
buildings collapsed in 1999 17 000
people were killed in ismet but there's
been nothing like this 7.8 magnitude
quake in more than 80 years the
epicenters of the main quake and a
second major Quake happened just 10 to
17 kilometers deep releasing more energy
on the surface and very near populated
areas I think we can expect the the
death toll um to uh to increase
significantly there's been a lot of
building collapses and it'll increase
more significantly around the epicenter
of of the earthquake the Earth is
enveloped by the cracked piece of the
Earth's crust tectonic plates that push
and slide against each other turkey sits
on the small Anatolian plate squeezed
between a northern fault line against
the Eurasian plate and the East
Anatolian fault line against the Arabian
plate where this earthquake happened
pressure builds over years and finally
gives and this time there was a second
powerful earthquake and more than a
hundred aftershocks The Raven Peninsula
and the Eurasian continent are colliding
and turkey is more or less caught in the
middle and so experiencing a lot of
compressive tectonic forces
the damage was spread over a large area
in Southeastern turkey and Northern
Syria the ancient and fortified Citadel
in Aleppo Syria that has stood for
centuries has sustained serious damage
specific earthquakes cannot be predicted
and can't be prevented turkey has
updated its building codes to improve
seismic resistance but whatever the
construction standards this Quake has
flattened thousands of buildings and
it's in or near buildings where most
people are killed and injured when you
see a lot of casualties it's because
there's a very dense population and
because the buildings have collapsed and
sometimes that's because of a failure of
building codes and sometimes it's just
you know earthquakes are really strong
and no matter how well you build a
building it might collapse the last time
turkey had a 7.8 magnitude Quake was
1939. the country's population then was
17 million today it's almost 87 million
as experts predicted the death toll is
climbing Eric Sorensen Global News
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm Donna Friesen we leave you
tonight with more images from the
earthquake zone where search crews are
working against time
thanks for watching
[Music]